[Musica]
buonasera buonasera a tutti io mi chiamo
alessandro e sono anch'io un analfabeta
funzionale o mi comporto come tale
qualche volta per lo meno è questa per
quanto possa sembrare strano era la
buona notizia quella cattiva è che
potreste esserlo anche voi potreste
diventarlo vi potreste comportare come
se lo foste in determinate situazioni
potreste non accorgervi può succedere a
chiunque
come dite non ci credete ok allora
facciamo così facciamo un bel esempio
pratico in cui magari vi potrete anche
riconoscere ed eccolo qua siamo su
whatsapp e dario fiocchetto è il mio
video maker quello che ha reso possibile
anche il video che state guardando
all'improvviso mi manda un articolo di
wired che dice cosa cambia nei nuovi
termini di servizio di youtube al suo
saluto classico quella hai visto segue
una frase che mi inquieta profondamente
dice youtube inserisce una nuova tassa
sui content creator è una bella rogna
ne parliamo in riunione ma nel frattempo
evita di caricare alcunché in
quell'istante qualcosa nella mia mente
scatta sento già il peso del mio
portafoglio che si assottiglia e
rispondo con una parolaccia che
oscureremo non è possibile che
continuino a cambiare incasinare tutto
capace che ci tocca pagare uno
sproposito con tutti i video che
mettiamo tario risponde con un po troppi
punti di sospensione è un bel problema è
nell'articolo spiegano tutto
dettagliatamente ma io continuo ignoro
il suo sottile suggerimento e dico che
cosa dicono gli altri youtuber non ha
veramente senso dario continua con una
sorta di sarcasmo sospetto disperazione
a iosa ma io ormai sono come un toro che
vede rosso finita che dovremo passare
pure noi su twitter
che palle adesso appena arrivo in
ufficio provo a scrivere all'assistenza
a youtube per chiedere spiegazioni e da
quando dovrebbe entrare in vigore sta
cosa
speriamo non sia pure retroattiva volevo
scrivere pure ho anche sbagliato a
digitare assolutamente poi mandami gli
screen dice dario me li mangio lario
risponde con un mio vecchio
in cui spiego che cosa sia
l'analfabetismo funzionale e poi
aggiunge magari leggiti l'articolo e fa
il caso che giorno è in quel momento il
realizzo che è il primo di aprile il mio
mondo crolla in un istante
leggo l'articolo ovviamente
nell'articolo non c'è scritto niente e
rispondo ma non c'è scritto nulla di
tasse o del genere ti odio puntini
puntini
madonna tiri cutter oa vita screen
immediati sei licenziato ed eccolo qua
un analfabeta funzionale superficiale e
distratto caduto come un pollo in una
stupida fake news creata dal suo video
maker è partito in quarta con
l'indignazione senza neanche aprire il
link e leggere l'articolo analfabeta
funzionale che poi dovrà comprare il
silenzio del suo video maker con un
sostanzioso aumento di stipendio e
pregherà ogni divinità maya dorata da
essere umano che nessuno venga mai a
saperlo finché non deciderà di
raccontarlo davanti a tutti ad un
tedesco bella mostra comunque questo
esempio imbarazzante che passerò i
prossimi minuti a tentare di rimuovere
della mia mente ci ha dato in realtà
un'idea un po più chiara un poco più
concreta di come stanno le cose
sì perché spesso non c'è davvero chiaro
che cosa voglia dire questo termine
analfabeta funzionale dopo averlo visto
spiegato in azione però possiamo
azzardare una definizione più teorica se
un analfabeta è una persona che da
definizione classica non è in grado di
leggere e scrivere o fare di conto
l'analfabeta funzionale e chi possiede
queste abilità di base ma non è in grado
di applicarle efficacemente alle
situazioni e ai contesti della sua vita
quotidiana fatica a comprendere un testo
da un articolo di giornale a una
bolletta non riesce a distinguere
notizie vere da notizie false è in
difficoltà con calcoli elementari
possiede scarse competenze nell'uso
degli strumenti informatici a delle
conoscenze certo riguardo al mondo ma
estremamente superficiali e legate
unicamente al suo contesto la sua
esperienza di vita a quello che vede
intorno a sé
manca di senso critico di capacità di
astrazione non riesce a valutare e
sfruttare le informazioni di cui entra
in possesso per raggiungere i suoi
obiettivi
le subisce un po di statistiche giusto
per deprimerci tutti insieme dati
nel 2016 in italia l'analfabetismo
funzionale del livello più grave è
generalizzato riguarderebbe il 27,9 per
cento della popolazione tra i 16 ei 65
anni
quasi una persona su tre secondo le
ricerche del programma dell'ocse che si
occupa di questo l'italia è agli ultimi
posti fra gli stati che hanno aderito
all'indagine in quasi tutti i campi
penultima per quanto riguarda le
competenze matematiche
sembra che rispetto a qualche anno fa la
situazione stia lentamente migliorando e
il gap si stia riducendo ma parliamo
ancora di un fenomeno incredibilmente
diffuso ma non è finita qui c'è un
problema nel problema e ci stiamo
finalmente avvicinando al cuore di
questo discorso
sì perché se è vero che possiamo
chiaramente individuare i frutti
amarissimi dell'analfabetismo funzionale
a livello sociale economico politico
criminologico basti pensare alla
diffusione devastante di fake news ha la
crescita dei movimenti populisti al
proliferare di gruppi whatsapp in cui i
nostri genitori si scambiano foto di
cagnolini con la scritta buongiorni
stimo caffè è altrettanto vero che
risulta ancora estremamente complesso
definirlo in maniera scientificamente
sensata studiare l'analfabetismo
funzionale e capirlo davvero in quanto
fenomeno non è davvero così chiaro come
determinare chi lo stia e chi non lo sia
un analfabeta funzionale e non si può
creare un vaccino per un virus che
nessuno sa isolare certo ci sono
proposte definizioni operative ma è
ancora difficile individuare esattamente
sulla base di quali variabili misurarlo
quali testa affrontare come
somministrarli come regolare e prendere
in considerazione gli influssi di
migliaia di fattori coinvolti si sa ad
esempio che il fenomeno è legato alla
scolarizzazione e alla formazione
eppure lo esibisce una percentuale
notevole anche di diplomati e dei
laureati si sa che il fenomeno è legato
alla condizione socio economica
eppure lo si ritrova prepotente anche in
contesti agiati si sa che è legato a
deficit cognitivi o condizioni
problematiche eppure coinvolge persone
senza alcuna difficoltà del genere si sa
che è correlato anche all'età eppure lo
si ritrova anche in giovani e
giovanissimi tutti fattori questi
comunque al di fuori del nostro
controllo diretto ci possiamo fare ben
poco il comune
la scienza in questo campo ancora
moltissima strada da fare e da
percorrere l'analfabetismo funzionale
non è ancora stato risolto solo
approssimato ed è qui che torniamo a noi
agli analfabeti funzionali anonimi a
questa sedia alla confessione con cui ho
aperto questo discorso perché forse il
punto che ci interessa davvero non è
tanto quello di determinare chi sia e
chi non sia un analfabeta funzionale non
è quello di applicare delle etichette ma
di capire come e perché chiunque in una
determinata condizione può comportarsi
come tale e contribuire ai disastri che
ne conseguono già chiunque davvero
chiunque
facciamo un esperimento mentale un
esperimento mentale stupido i miei
preferiti
prendiamo la persona che nel nostro
immaginario collettivo è la più lontana
in assoluto dal concetto di
analfabetismo funzionale la più lontana
che ci possa venire in mente una persona
che simboleggi l'intelligenza la
scientificità la schiacciante
superiorità dell'inter è albert einstein
è proprio lui capelli baffi pipa e
cervello compresi ora nessuno di noi ha
dei dubbi sul fatto che einstein non
rientri non rientrasse nel normale
stereotipo che ci si può fare
dell'analfabeta funzionale bene ma
immaginiamo se lo però dopo una giornata
di lavoro di fronte a 4 schermi
bombardato di e mail esasperato stanco
con il capo che gli rompe le palle senza
alcuna conoscenza delle lingue straniere
si ritrova all'improvviso fra le mani
uno smartphone di cui non comprende
neanche la metà delle funzioni apre un
social network a caso del quale non ha
la minima cognizione mentre al tempo
stesso gli arrivano le notifiche di sua
cugina che gli scrive su whatsapp e
all'improvviso si trova davanti
questo no vabbè dai non esageriamo
diciamo questo ancora troppo va bene
povero albert proviamo con questo ecco
questo sì ora secondo voi spinto a
commentare il post di gello si
comporterebbe in modo più simile a un
premio nobel o un analfabeta funzionale
si renderebbe conto di trovarsi di
fronte a una fake news aprirebbe
l'articolo lo leggerebbe la verità è che
non lo sappiamo ma se io dovessi
scommettere direi che probabilmente
anche uno come einstein e ne uscirebbe
fuori tanto bene da quella situazione e
il caps lock è sempre dietro l'angolo
ma allora
cosa dobbiamo fare noi poveri analfabeti
funzionale anonimi
ce n'è anche einstein è in grado di
salvarsi voglio parlarvi di quattro
fattori che possono contribuire a farci
comportare da analfabeti funzionali e
darvi però altrettanti consigli per
tenerli a bada
partiamo dal primo dal cosiddetto
information overload che in inglese
suona pure figo ma se ve lo dico in
italiano fa più paura sovraccarico
cognitivo da informazioni sono meno
accattivante adesso vero no ecco siamo
bombardati di informazioni come non mai
nella storia dell'umanità sono troppe e
troppo rapide troppo diverse tra loro e
il nostro cervello non si è evoluto per
gestirle e il motivo anzi i motivi sono
semplici internet ei media di massa
leggiamo sempre di meno e scorriamo
sempre di più il testo ci zombie fi
chiamo scorrendo la lista di netflix
senza riuscire a prendere una decisione
interrompiamo continuamente quello che
stiamo pensando facendo dice scusate se
è arrivata è arrivata una notifica
mi sono pure comprato un telefono che si
apre così ho più schermo per poter
contemporaneamente leggere le mail
mentre rispondo su whatsapp e nel
frattempo mi guardo oppure un video di
montemagno
tornando a noi ci svegliamo la mattina e
la prima cosa che facciamo è immergerci
in un flusso da qui non siamo più in
grado di uscire il sovraccarico
cognitivo ci porta alla superficialità
al multitasking all'eccessiva fretta
alla mancanza di tempo e di risorse per
fermarci ad analizzare criticamente
ed ecco che li l'analfabetismo
funzionale si sfrega le mani
dobbiamo reclamare il nostro diritto
dovere al mono tasking alle notifiche
silenziate al fare una cosa alla volta e
farla bene e io lo ammetto predico bene
su questo palco virtuale ma razzola
malissimo nella mia vita e il flusso di
informazioni mi schiavizza ma la verità
è che se vogliamo esprimere le nostre
abilità e competenze al massimo livello
esercitando il nostro senso critico la
nostra capacità di analisi
dobbiamo imparare se non ad arrestare
quantomeno a dirigere quel flusso a
fermarlo quando ci serve provate a fare
così terapia d'urto
togliete le notifiche e silenziate tutti
i social e tutte le app che non sono
strettamente essenziali per il vostro
lavoro o la vostra vita personale
fate in modo che solo le persone
importanti possano interrompervi per
tutto il resto
dovrete intenzionalmente aprire
un'applicazione poi scombinate le icone
delle applicazioni stesse sullo schermo
del vostro smartphone è cambiata lady
posto almeno una volta alla settimana
per rompere gli automatismi e in ultimo
abituatevi a prestare attenzione a
quando fate più cose insieme e ritornate
a un solo compito alla volta
multitasking vietato
il secondo fattore è la mancanza di
comprensione del contesto specie sui
social network fermatevi un secondo a
pensare quanto tempo è passato
dall'ultima volta che avete aperto sul
vostro smartphone
un social qualunque facebook e youtube
instagram twitter tik tok langdon reddit
quello che vi pare
quanto tempo dieci minuti un'ora un
minuto quando invece l'ultima volta che
avete letto un libro con calma e
attenzione
ormai viviamo tutti dentro ai social
network sono una parte enorme delle
nostre vite ma se ci pensate ancora è
qualcosa di nuovissimo questo facebook è
nato nel 2004 17 anni fa youtube nel
2005 twitter nel 2006 instagram nel 2009
tik tok nel 2016 è una tecnologia
neonata non ne sappiamo nulla e ancora
meno ne sanno quelli che non sono nati e
cresciuti utilizzandoli è normale che si
faccia fatica ad usarli in modo critico
ad abitarli in modo civile a
comprenderne i meccanismi profondi e non
parlo soltanto per i boomer e non
pensate per forza di cose allo zio che
condivide le fake news razziste
scambiando i punti esclamativi con gli 1
quando io avevo 18 anni
facebook era la novità del momento e io
ne ho trentadue di anni non 60 e allora
sì i social giocano con le nostre
emozioni ci rendono irrazionali ci
chiudono in bolle che ci radicalizzano e
ciad è strano a commentare prima di
capire a indignarci prima di cliccare
come è successo a me con quell'articolo
a scrollare prima di pensare e chi non
li abita
di frequente o non ha avuto il tempo le
risorse per capirne la sottocultura per
impararne i funzionamenti profondi si
ritroverà spiazzato e più probabilmente
si comporterà come un analfabeta
funzionale prima di scrivere prima di
commentare prima di chattare e
arrabbiarmi per un articolo che non dice
nemmeno quello che pensate prima di
farvi
prendere dalle emozioni per quello che
leggete un non leggete fermatevi a
ragionare sul contesto dove vi trovate
di che social network o che giornale o
rivista o programma televisivo o chat si
tratta
quali sono le sue regole la sua
atmosfera conquistate dialogando è per
caso coinvolta dell'ironia
potrebbe trattarsi di una notizia falsa
c'è anche chi la pensa diversamente
ci sono delle fonti che potete
verificare quello che sto digitando o
dicendo è appropriato al contesto non è
che magari insultare pubblicamente
un'alta carica dello stato fa rischiare
dei guai deve diventare come un riflesso
automatico un'abitudine un'abitudine
consolidata affermarsi mettere in
discussione valutare e soppesare prima
di reagire
terzo fattore fondamentale ad acuire il
nostro analfabetismo funzionale latente
la lingua anzi le lingue inglese in
primis ma anche l'italiano dirla tutta
non sarebbe male approfondirlo un po e
comunque il mondo intero
specialmente quello che gira su internet
impiega sempre più terminologie legate
alla lingua della regina elisabetta e
diventa sempre più grave non averne una
conoscenza almeno basilare
non solo ma ci sono i prestiti
linguistici i neologismi libri di un
parco giochi per i linguisti di tutto il
mondo un incubo per chi naviga la realtà
senza conoscerli un terreno di ignoranza
più che fertile per il nostro
analfabetismo funzionale preferito sarà
banale ma impariamo lo l'inglese
familiarizziamo con i neologismi
dell'informazione o di internet
se c'è una parola un'espressione una
frase che non comprendiamo davvero
fermiamoci e andiamo a scoprirne il
significato prima di proseguire la
lettura o l'ascolto sempre senza
eccezioni
io lo chiamo l'approccio del carro
armato uno degli elementi cardine della
lettura efficace ci si assicura di aver
compreso bene
una frase un concetto e solo poi si
passa al prossimo più vento sul breve
periodo forse ma più sicuro più
funzionale
infine ultimo fattore ma non ultimo per
importanza la mancanza di abitudine all
analisi profonda allo studio la
passività la diminuzione progressiva
delle ore dei giorni passati a leggere
davvero o ascoltare davvero imparare
davvero sperimentare davvero siamo
collettivamente arrugginiti al pensiero
critico all'apprendimento e alla ricerca
siamo fuori allenamento
più ci impieghiamo e più diventiamo
incapaci di applicare le competenze
linguistiche di calcolo di pensiero che
abbiamo appreso con il percorso
dell'istruzione e allora teniamoci in
allenamento leggiamo ascoltiamo
discutiamo
usciamo dalla nostra bolla studiamo
impariamo qualcosa di nuovo giochiamo
poniamo domande
indaghiamo ritorniamo ad essere
protagonisti del nostro rapporto con le
informazioni con la realtà e smettiamo
di essere spettatori passivi
abituiamoci a partecipare attivamente a
tutto quello che ci passa davanti la
modalità zombie può essere combattuta e
sconfitta promesso consiglio bonus
smettiamo di cercare qualcun altro a cui
affibbiare la definizione di analfabeta
funzionale iniziamo a guardarci allo
specchio anzi riflessi sullo schermo che
abbiamo tra le mani magari allora ci
ritroveremo qui fra qualche anno nel
nostro circolo degli analfabeti
funzionali anonimi e forse avremo
qualche storia imbarazzante in meno la
condivide grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]